way thank you guys
should americans be worried about
inflation sir
well i i really
doubt that we're going to see an
inflationary cycle and by the way
talking inflation
the overwhelming consensus is going to
pop up a little bit and then go back
down
i don't know anybody including larry
summers who's a friend of mine who's
worried about inflation
what's up people i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report it's july 28 2022
we're live streaming on rumble youtube
and blaze tv subscribe if you have not
and despite
what the elderly man pretending to be
president has said repeatedly over the
last year
a recession is here uh it was basically
just announced this morning although the
machine and you always have to watch out
for the machine the machine is currently
trying to
change the definition of recession we
got into this a little bit yesterday
about what the technical definition of
recession is what the definition of
recession has always been and what the
very same people who are now saying
we're not in a recession we're basically
saying when you know trump was president
and we weren't in a recession but they
were kind of trying to pretend we're in
a recession because they didn't like the
orange man well here we are so we're
going to be uh pointing out a lot of
hypocrisy and nonsense and editing of
words in real time because that's what's
happening across the uh the internet and
throughout this culture war that we find
ourselves in and uh we're going to frame
today's show
around uh an interview that i did a
couple years ago that i'm guessing
probably 90 percent of you have seen uh
with economist uh thomas soule it's
probably my favorite interview that i've
ever done
and
there's a lot of reasons for that but i
think sort of most importantly is that i
tried to treat the interview
as sort of a 101 for a lot of people who
were just waking up out of leftist
insanity waking up to oh maybe there
should be limited government maybe
regulation doesn't work maybe these
programs don't work i was going through
that evolution myself and i think that's
why so many people
were appreciative of the interview and
the reason we're going to use that today
is the frame or the framework
is because it's not as if we couldn't
have predicted
that if you spend endlessly and you
hamper the economy and you lock people
down and you keep them out of jobs and
all those things it's not as if we
couldn't have predicted that this was
going to happen because many people have
been warning about it for a long
time so
before we get to any of that i have to
talk to you about the view yeah we got
to do it sorry a lot of you enjoyed
yesterday's show uh some of my language
uh michael you particularly enjoyed my
language around the ladies of the view i
got a lot of texts yesterday people that
were watching it like having lunch like
cracking up over some of the things that
i said about those crazy harpies um but
uh what you know what happened basically
a couple days ago uh whoopi and the
ladies of the view uh accused turning
point at their student action summit
which i was at and ron desantis was at
and president trump was at and greg
gutfeld was that and plenty of other
people were at charlie kirk of course uh
which was all about freedom and
laissez-faire economics and being proud
of america and individual rights and all
of that you know crazy far-right stuff
uh whoopi accused them of embracing and
welcoming in neo-nazis on the show the
other day then they went to commercial
break the lawyers obviously freaked out
whoopi gave this very half-assed apology
saying that she meant it metaphorically
that they welcomed them in not literally
which actually made no sense and in some
ways made it even worse that they were
because if you're metaphorically
welcoming in nazis it's
irrelevant whether you're welcome into
the building you're sort of doing it
with everything else that you got you're
doing it spiritually which of course is
complete nonsense turning point was
turning them away the students were
mocking them several of the speeches
were making fun of those very same
collectivist ideas anyway the view
really really stepped in it and it was
the thing online yesterday so then the
view now has had to issue even a further
apology because whoopi's metaphorical
apology didn't quite cut it here is
sarah haynes of the view
trying to unstep in
s-h-i-t
everybody and i have to stop talking
because you have that night i do have
sorry so on monday we talked about the
fact that there were openly neo-nazi
demonstrators outside the florida
student action summit of the turning
point usa group we want to make clear
that these demonstrate demonstrators
were gathered outside the event and that
they were not invited or endorsed by
turning point usa a turning point usa
spokesman said the group quote 100
condemns those ideologies and said
turning point usa security tried to
remove the neo-nazis from the area but
could not because they were on public
property also turning point usa wanted
to clarify i wanted us to clarify that
this was a turning point usa summit and
not a republican party event so we
apologize for anything we said that may
have been unclear on these points they
still invited matt gates though i would
just like to know
just at the end there they still invited
matt gates so is the are they gonna have
to issue another apology because the
implication of course is that matt gates
is a nazi anyway there's just something
interesting about this just something
interesting about these people who throw
out these bombs oh those people are
nazis and they're associated with you
and even if you have nothing to do with
them we're going to make these baseless
accusations we're going to tar all of
you make sure you're not invited to
polite society and then finally
finally what is starting to happen is
people on the right are fighting back it
has taken a long time but finally
somebody at turning point obviously made
a call to a lawyer and one lawyer called
another lawyer and that lawyer over at
abc picked up the phone and said uh oh
we we are in it if we don't issue
another apology so then there's another
just half-assed disingenuous apology and
of course whoopi didn't actually make
the apology uh nor joy behar who implied
that ron desantis was working with the
nazis i mean it's all just silliness
nonsense but i thought it was worth
putting a cap on that after yesterday's
big show uh anyway today we are going to
talk about the recession that is not a
recession if you're a democrat who
changes terms oh by the way clyde's in
studio i said recession and he groaned
he hates recessions that's the big thing
with the dogs because they know the
treats might uh disappear
before we get to any of that though real
quick guys let me talk about liquid iv
uh you know the hot summer months are
here in miami florida and david and i
need to be proactive about keeping our
bodies fueled and hydrated making a
hydration a priority can help us feel
healthier in our everyday lives one
stick of liquid iv and i have many
sticks right here has in 16 ounces of
water hydrates you two times faster and
more efficiently than water alone plus
liquid iv tastes great with 10
refreshing flavors like concord grape
lemon lime pina colada and tropical
punch sounds like summer doesn't it i
used liquid iv last night after coming
back from a marlins game with the team
we went to the marlins game again we
love the marlins big marlins fans i love
how it makes me feel on a daily basis
pina colada is my personal favorite
flavor grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidity.com and use
code ruben at checkout that's 25 off
anything when you shop for better
hydration today use promo code reuben at
liquidity.com i've got the lemon lime in
my hand right here okay so let's frame
today's show about the recession that is
not a recession except it is a recession
around some people who have been making
sense because it is not like none of us
could have predicted this it is not like
there aren't economists who believe in
reality who have been trying to preach
about this stuff for a long time
would be shocked at what has happened
today with endless spending and all of
that stuff so let's flash back
to an interview i did with
thomas soule
the brilliant thomazol i don't even add
intro and prop really like the brilliant
economist thomas soul probably of all
people in american culture today like if
there's one person that should be more
well known for his good work it is
thomas soul uh stanford professor uh he
is author of probably 20 or 25 books i
mean
there's just nothing you can say about
the guy because you can say everything
about him this is thomas sol on the
rubin report
discussing the us government's perverse
incentive with macroeconomics and why
the endless spending and all that stuff
kind of doesn't work this about four
years ago take a look then what was your
wake up to what was wrong with that line
of thinking uh facts
[Laughter]
well you know we could probably end the
interview right there
facts
my first professional job i was a
summer intern at the us department of
labor
and i realized from dealing with these
people
that the u.s department of labor one of
my biggest concern was about minimum
wages it has been for a long time
and so my my at first i thought this is
good because all these people are poor
and they'll get a little higher income
and so that'll that'll be helpful
and then
as i studied economics i began to say
well there's a downside they may lose
their jobs completely so
that's that's that and so i try and i
when i was at the labor department i
tried to
talk about that to them and eventually i
came up with some tests of it and uh
when i came up with this test how we
might test this i was waiting to hear
congratulations you see that i had this
and i could see these people were
stunned they said oh this this idiot has
stumbled on something that would ruin us
all wow
and i realized the us department of
labor had its own agenda and interest
uh and that didn't necessarily not
necessarily mean that that that whether
poor people lost their jobs or minimum
wages or got higher pay was their
highest priority yeah how much longer
did you last after no that that would no
that was really the turning point yeah
and then i began to see that all these
government agencies whatnot they have
their own institutional incentives
and uh you cannot say that the
government will step in and do what's
right for these people and whatnot
because they'll do what's right for
themselves
so the interview goes for about an hour
if you haven't seen it guys let's link
to it uh below if you haven't seen the
full thing uh but his anecdote there and
the thesis that he's laying out that
these institutions these government
institutions the swamp as some people
call it they have their own agenda that
often has very little to do with solving
the problems that they purport to solve
so he goes in there as a lefty as a
government guy he moments before that he
was describing himself at that time as a
marxist so he's a big government guy he
goes in he finds out that these programs
do not work and basically everyone's
like whoa whoa whoa we're in the
government we're not in the business of
solving problems we just want our
endless budget to go up every year to do
absolutely nothing and actually harm the
people we're supposed to be helping so
that is the perfect jumping off point
for what is going on with our
leaders leaders what are we calling
these people today here is head of the
fed jerome powell announcing that the
fed has increased uh the interest rates
and uh do you think there might be a
reason for that good afternoon
my colleagues and i are strongly
committed to bringing inflation back
down and we're moving expeditiously to
do so
we have both the tools we need and the
resolve it will take to restore price
stability on behalf of american families
and businesses
the economy and the country have been
through a lot over the past two and a
half years and have proved resilient
it is essential that we bring inflation
down to our two percent goal if we are
to have a sustained period of strong
labor market conditions that benefit all
from the standpoint of our congressional
mandate to promote maximum employment
and price stability
the current picture is plain to see
the labor market is extremely tight and
inflation is much too high
against this backdrop today the fomc
raised its policy interest rate by three
quarters of a percentage point
and anticipates that ongoing increases
in the target range for the federal
funds rate will be appropriate
okay so if only any of us could have
seen this coming this is so shocking
aren't you freaking out what do you mean
that there could be a problem with the
economy i mean we printed all that money
we
broke all those businesses we destroyed
all of those companies we did all that
stuff and we locked everyone in and all
that i can't believe that it would lead
to this i'm freaking out it's very
bizarre well then what happened at
officially 8 30 this morning 8 30
eastern time
it was announced that we had our second
consecutive negative quarter of gdp in
the u.s economy that has been the
technical definition of a recession for
probably
100 years probably a century or so
that's what everyone has always said
we've got evidence of that we'll show
you in just a second
but
not our people in charge right now
here's black lesbian korean jean-pierre
she is the white house press secretary
uh and she's telling peter ducey that
the thing that we've always known is not
really the thing if things are going so
great though then why is it the white
house officials are trying to redefine
recession no we're not redefining
recession if we all understand a
recession to be two consecutive quarters
of negative gdp growth in a row and then
you have white house officials come up
here to say no no that's not what a
recession is it's something else how is
that not redefining recession because
that's not the definition
that is not the definition
said in 2008 of course economists have a
technical definition
which is of a recession which is two
consecutive quarters
of negative growth
i can tell you this they said two
consecutive two negative quarters of gdp
growth is not the technical definition
of recession it is not it is not why did
he say that it is not i can i can speak
to i can speak to you to what he said
yesterday in front of all of you which
is the last thing that you just repeated
there are many factors there are many
factors economic factors and indicators
to consider
and
i will say that the textbook definition
of recession is not is not two negative
quarters of gdp
okay so you know she just lies like
they're so in the lies it's all they can
do uh she never actually we watch the
full clip she never actually explains
then if it's not the common definition
of two consecutive quarters of the gdp
shrinking that uh if that's not the
definition of recession what it is uh
but what's interesting that peter ducey
who is just fantastic i mean he really
out of all the people in the white house
press corps he's just doing a great job
for fox and he's really the only one
asking these direct questions uh he
brings up this guy brian diese
who is joe biden's national economic the
head of the national economic council
he's the director uh here's the exact
quote i this is what ducey read but i
just thought it was worth showing you
guys again this is the guy that's in
charge of the national economic council
right now for joe biden well what did he
say back in march of 2008 economists
have a technical definition of recession
which is two consecutive quarters of
negative growth
this is the guy who's in charge of the
thing for the elderly man pretending to
be president right now
he's also a black rock guy but let's
just that's a little sidebar thing but
the point is that they are going to try
to change the definition of words right
now these are the same people who try to
change the definition of everything
right boys or girls two plus two is five
uh you know just being non-racist is
actually being racist and the rest of
those things and you can now watch
what's fascinating this is what we're
going to get to in a second is now
watching the entire machine just do it
right in front of us and this is what
they do all the time they do the magic
trick right in front of us even though
we know how they're doing the magic
trick and yet a certain amount of people
uh still get bamboozled by it real quick
though guys i want to talk to you about
blaze socks the blaze has a limited
release of fantastic socks just in time
for the primaries and back to school
shopping guys you've got ron desantis
riding an alligator alligator with big d
energy you could pretend that's you
could pretend that's dave rubin in a
suit up there if you want to get that
one riding an alligator with his big d
energy that's what they say people come
up to me dave you've got big d energy
you can have uh klaus schwab doing his
evil darth vader-like thing you lilly
the bugs joe biden riding a car
into hell
and many more people go to blaze
blazesocks.com before they're gone uh
and you can use promo code blaze sub for
20 off your purchase if you're already a
blaze subscriber so jump over there and
get some socks
keep your feet warm and fight for
freedom okay so
i want to show you just how the machine
operates because it's not just that they
promote all of the bad ideas and that
they hide the good ideas right it's like
why don't more people know about thomas
soul it's because he was telling the
truth for a long time but the truth went
against the narrative so we just kind of
hide him but then we inflate these faux
economists these lefty economists who
get everything wrong guys like new york
times paul krugman we'll get to him in
just a sec but watch even what the the
places of journalism air quotes
journalism watch what they do when it's
their guy in power versus say when it's
orange man in power we've got two tweets
here from politico this is just
fantastic logan hall came up with this
uh over comparing the first one and the
second one so the first one this is what
they said yesterday about joe biden and
the disastrous economy tomorrow we get
the first possibly inaccurate and
certain to be revised reading of u.s
economic performance in the second
quarter of this deeply weird economic
year
one metric to measure if we're in a
recession so you can see it's full of
you know there's problems and it's not
really his problems and it's a very
weird year and you know we shouldn't
really blame joe biden now what happened
when trump was president and things were
actually going well things were actually
going well here's what politico said
about trump trump is expected to get a
badly needed positive headline thursday
morning with a report expected to show
the economy grew at a record pace in
third quarters but beneath the headline
the economic picture looks far less
sunny so do you get what they do there
when it was donald trump and things were
going well they're warning you that
underneath the good things that are
happening bad things are happening when
it's joe biden and things are going
poorly they're telling you it's a weird
time so don't actually tell anyone that
things aren't going well don't tell them
that the house is about to fall on their
head these people can't deal with it
here is uh ben white he is the chief
economic correspondent also for politico
this is just spectacular like i don't
really care who this guy is but it's
just the way these people operate when
it's their guys versus the other guys so
this is ben white yesterday chief
economic correspondent at politico the
white house is pretty obviously right
that even two quarters of shrinking gdp
would not show the economy is currently
in recession getting people to
understand uh that and the nuances of
our strange vexing economic movement is
just really hard by me and here's his
article and then this guy this is just
fantastic this guy jeff billman i don't
know who this guy is he just went into
one of uh morning ben's tweets one of
his old articles just from a couple
months ago this is literally from a
month and a half ago you wrote this in
june and here's exactly what he said i'm
sorry to report that conditions are ripe
for a slide in gross domestic product
growth that lasts at least two quarters
the technical definition of recession
you get it you get it the way the
machine covers up for certain people and
the way that they try to destroy
the other set of people when they're
doing good things here's paul krugman
from the new york times this is a man
who has gotten everything wrong ever for
his entire life so he's a perfect
economist for the new york times he says
ignore the two-quarter rule we might
have a recession but we aren't in one
now so he's telling you to not see what
you can see right in front of your face
just try to imagine if this was orange
man or this was desantis or this was pet
romney or any other republican do you
think the entire machine would be
running around to redefine recession or
would they be telling you that the sky
is falling that the sky is falling
that's exactly what they would be
telling you chicken little and all of
her friends would be dead right now
that's what they would be telling you
it's just
incredible uh but let's go uh full
circle here uh remember that brian diese
guy here is uh heon here he is on cnn
and let's contrast that with uh what i
just read to you he was saying back in
2008. all signs are that this is a
strong economy and the probability of a
recession within the next year is not
particularly elevated it's a strong
economy and nothing about it suggests
that it's that it's close to or
vulnerable to
a recession i don't expect a recession
no one is predicting a recession now we
are not expecting that we are already in
the recession in fact the guts and the
bones of this economy remain strong
these are not the marks of an economy in
recession right now we don't see a
recession right now that is not we're
not in a recession right now this is not
an economy that's in recession not only
is a recession not inevitable but i
think that a lot of people are
underestimating those strengths and the
resilience of the american economy we
have a strong labor market which you
don't normally see
in a recession a recession is
broad-based weakness in the economy
we're not seeing that now in your view
is a recession in the united states
inevitable
no typically economists date a recession
as being at least two quarters of
negative growth uh and other comp and
other factors which we have not seen at
all the idea that uh two quarters of
negative gdp growth is a technical
definition of a recession is wrong a
common definition of recession is two
negative quarters of gdp growth two
quarters of negative growth in a row
that's a recession
right and certainly the in terms of the
technical definition it's not a
recession the technical definition
considers a much broader spectrum
okay so that was obviously a compilation
of a bunch of the people that are in
this clown car uh contradicting
themselves redefining words and
everything else that was brian diese
right at the end there
the same guy who gave us the technical
definition now saying it's not quite the
technical definition let's not forget
there's also janet yellen she has hope
that all hell isn't breaking loose i
mean these are just completely
incompetent buffoons but you guys know i
like that silver lining thing people are
waking up to it and they're waking up to
it bigly as a certain orange man used to
say and we'll get to that in a second
let me talk to you about eugenics real
quick do you want more energy to counter
the negative effects of aging eugenics
total t testosterone booster with
testofin will help you turn back the
clock re-energize your workouts and get
you better results at the gym and help
you look and feel like the man you
really want to be eugenics total tea
contains man boosting key ingredients
like testophin it has been validated in
five clinical studies shown to boost
free testosterone levels in men because
eugenics total t boasts boosts free
testosterone that the aging process robs
you'll feel stronger leaner with more
energy and drive and more passion too
your partner will notice the difference
while every product professes quality
many other products use generic
ingredients that are often far less than
clinical grade with eugenics total tea
you get the same clinical potency levels
used in the trials and eugenics
formulation is backed by 10 years of
science and research eugenics total t is
the number one selling testosterone
booster at gnc and you can get a
complimentary bottle of eugenics total
tea when you text reuben to 231-231
text now and get a bottle of eugenics
thermo their most powerful fat
incinerator ever with key ingredients to
help you get back into shape absolutely
free text 231 text reuben two three one
two three one text reuben two three one
two three one and now back to me all
right so this is not going well for joe
biden and in that compilation we just
showed you they said are we going into a
recession and while everyone else said a
whole bunch of things joe just said no
except the truth is yes
we are in one that's just how it is uh
this is this is just spectacular so we
found this is a throwback to the uh the
2016 debate was the 2016 election so
this is technically in 2015 the debate
between joseph r biden and donald j
trump and uh well take a look
if you're a middle class family you're
getting hurt badly right now you're
sitting at the kitchen table this
morning deciding well we can't get new
tires they're bald because we have to
wait another month or so
10 seconds mr president ten seconds
political statement let's get off this
china thing and then he looks the family
around the table everything just a
typical politician when i see that let's
talk about not a typical politician okay
that's why i got elected come on joe you
can do better we're gonna talk about
i grew up in a family
where when the price of gasoline went up
at the pump it was a conversation at the
kitchen table with my dad where prices
went up for things were daily
requirements like the gallon of gasoline
it became a discussion at the kitchen
table it mattered we felt it it was a
discussion at the kitchen table you felt
it it was a discussion at the kitchen
table with on the kitchen table and
around your kitchen table on our kitchen
table fell at the kitchen table on the
kitchen table and around our kitchen
tables around the kitchen table in the
morning feeling your own lives around
the kitchen table talk about around your
kitchen table
and i learned that at the kitchen table
in scranton my dad just said the end of
the day it's just when you sit at that
table do you have enough money to pay
for everything you need
so isn't that just such a perfect
explanation of what thomas soul said at
the top of the show that these people
have an agenda they say certain things
we're here to help
the little guy we want to help
minorities etc etc we want people around
the kitchen table to know that they're
going to have food and all that but it's
their policies
that take food off the kitchen table
that put more people into unemployment
and hurt the the bank statements and
make you look when you get your check
and you go boy i just gave that much
more to the government and i got nothing
for that money so if he cared about any
of these people if he had paid attention
perhaps at the kitchen table to some
other things that he could have been
reading or listening to or watching
maybe we'd be in better shape but we
ain't and people get it cnn now cannot
hide it anymore we've been showing you a
bunch of these over the last couple
weeks the people do not like joe bite
tonight 75
the vast majority of democrats three out
of four don't want biden to be their
nominee in 2024. that is according to a
new cnn poll out front now david axelrod
former senior adviser to president obama
david i i heard that and sort of stopped
in my tracks for a second three quarters
of democrats don't want the incumbent
president to run again
uh how worried should biden be right now
about that
well i mean obviously this is a this is
a very unhappy uh bit of data for him
and i'm sure
you know
it is concerning
look you got to remember cnn does not
want to run these things right they want
to run cover for him the last thing they
want is a faltering stammering
disastrous joe biden and a collapsing
economy which then could lead to the
return of donald trump or tyron desantis
or any republican or a red wave in the
midterms et cetera et cetera it's funny
how they operate of course you know that
guy david axelrod there he was an obama
senior aide right so it's like you're
bringing on an obama senior aide uh who
was obama's vp yeah that was joe biden
so it's like you're already having like
the insidious nature of all of this this
is exactly what the swamp is you bring
on a guy who kind of worked with the guy
he's supposed to kind of criticize but
you know he also likes and doesn't want
the other guy to win it's just it's just
so awful and i know you guys can see
through it it's it's easy enough but
it's not just that the average person
the average democrat is just like biden
just ain't up to the task now even the
tacos as dr jill biden calls them the
breakfast tacos the delicious what kind
of breakfast taco do you like quick
let's do it again
you love the carne asada breakfast taco
carne asada too
breakfast taco
bean burrito you like a bean burrito
daphne
steak that is also carne asada okay we
got a lot of red meat eaters in here the
point is the democrats love their little
breakfast tacos they love thinking that
they can give these people something or
that the latino community that the
hispanic community is just this monolith
that if you treat everyone the same
despite all the different countries they
come from and all their different
backgrounds and desires and all of those
things if we just pander to them in
equal terms we're going to keep getting
these people to vote for us and by the
way it has worked for a long time but
according to this new quinnipiac poll it
ain't working much longer democrats
losing a huge classically reliable base
with a latino vote a new quinnipia
quinnipiac poll finding that president
biden's support among hispanics is just
19 percent right now
whoa
whoo
19 for the record i like the fish taco
generally a grilled mahi mahi or grouper
but also you know if it's fried it's all
right in a fish taco here's joe biden's
response
i just have
one thing to say
how you're going here
all right
[Music]
81 million people i'm told voted for
that pandering disastrous buffoon there
he is he's at some hispanic conference
and he walks up there and plays
despocito
i like this position it's just fine okay
but this is what they do they think of
you if you're watching this
is watching this right now what they
think you are is just a little piece on
a chessboard that they can move around
and give you just little crumbs and that
you will always vote for them but it's
not working anymore and it's really it's
actually quite spectacular how it's
collapsing
so quickly then we came up we saw this
video yesterday this one was going
around online and look there is
something going on with biden and as i
often say it's like i can make fun of
the guy and all of that stuff and the
media can keep running you know running
cover for him and carrying water for him
and all that but something is seriously
going on with him uh so somebody put
together this compilation what you're
about to see here it's about a 30 second
video where they're gonna go back and
forth this is this is joe biden on the
same day both of these videos you're
about to see are on the same day do you
think something is going on with him
note his face his tone
eyes jus just watch this this is two
videos from the same day same day you
got the point same day same day folks as
we fight inflation you can't be pro
insurrection and pro cop
bringing down gas prices is a big part
of the job
you can't be pro-insurrection and
pro-democracy you can't be
pro-insurrection and pro-american
and here's the good news
gas prices have dropped every day this
summer
that's more than 40 days in a row donald
trump lacked the courage to act we now
have 40 000 gas stations in the united
states where the price of gas is 3.99 or
less
the brave women and men in blue all
across this nation
should never forget that
i mean if that doesn't freak you out i
don't know what will you like is he a
synthetic humanoid that is breaking down
like if he got a little too close to
heat it would melt and you'd see the
terminator robot beneath the eyes that
are like this that he can't blink the
voice that's different like what are
they drugging him with what is going on
here it is a conspiracy in front of all
of our faces i'm sorry it just is the
conspiracy is the non-conspiracy right
because there is a conspiracy but that's
not even the interesting part like it's
there is a conspiracy that they are
drugging him and something's not right
with him and a whole bunch of people
know it the conspiracy is that no one
will talk about it honestly that's
really what it is but i still think like
it really could take down all of these
people all of these people who know it
from dr jill to kamala to everybody else
like they're in dereliction of their
duty which is to defend the constitution
of the united states and if the man in
charge is losing his mind and cannot
blink
and doesn't know where he is or or
whatever else is going on there then
these people are just not very good at
what they're supposed to do but let's go
full circle look the point is that the
guy in the administration and the dems
are losing the agenda's not working it's
hurting americans we all know it we all
know it uh and then we thought this
would be interesting because we've
obviously referenced thomas seoul today
and that elderly man pretending to be
president he's always sort of been a
buffoon and in 1987
thomas soule who at the time was an
economist at stanford he was doing a
senate hearing
and they were talking about racism sort
of systemic racism before the phrase
systemic racism was cool oh this was
during the robert bork hearings also so
they this is during the robert burke
areas then it got sort of sidetracked by
some stuff about racism and listen to
what a pandering buffoon joe biden is as
he talks to one of the the brightest
economists in the country who happens to
be a black man and looks now just great
thomas solis it's just fantastic how
about literacy test
was that you did
i see no problem no reason why people
shouldn't be literate in order to vote
the question is if you have a black who
comes in with his degree from harvard
and the man behind the desk says no
you're not illiterate you can't vote
then this you see this is what bothers
me people are talking about how
judges should be sensitive to this
particular group or that particular
group and if that means anything if it
means he's applying the law differently
that's precisely how blacks were held
down for generations in the southwest so
they're saying the law differently
yeah you get it thomas soul right there
then and there this is almost 40 years
ago just full-on assault on identity
politics before we all fully knew what
identity politics was before we knew how
it was going to leak into everything and
of course biden is somehow trying to
make it seem that if he's for these
literacy tests that somehow thomas soule
is the racist there so it's a clash of
ideologies that's been going on for a
really really long time but biden's
agenda whether it was his agenda back in
87 to make it seem like thomas solar is
a racist or whether it was his economic
agenda right now which is clearly
destroying the economy and my personal
belief is that it's intentional it just
ain't working and a lot of people are
waking up to it so i want to finish up
with a little more thomas soul here
because i thought i thought this was
interesting i asked him
about my awakening and what people need
to do today
so i think a lot of people watching this
and i know because i've been so open
about my own sort of awakening are going
through this right now they're realizing
that the things that they've been taught
for so long are not
the the truth and are not based in fact
when that happened to you and you
started telling other people not just
the people you were working with be it
family or friends what kind of pushback
did you get because it was sort of
radical ideas in a way that you were
talking about that well i actually i
didn't feel any need to
do a lot of proselytizing uh it was
enough for me
that that i i was now beginning to
understand things i hadn't understood
before
i love that i love that he was beginning
to understand things that's what's
happening across the country i really
think that is like the little red pill
that's being doled out amongst people
right now a lot of people
that didn't really care about politics
that weren't in this culture war they're
starting to see things a little bit
differently they're starting to think
about things a little bit differently
they're starting to go hey you know all
these years after lockdowns and
everything maybe uh maybe the government
really isn't looking out for me and then
you see cultural icons start testing the
waters guys like joe rogan who was a
bernie supporter suddenly saying he
could vote for desantis guys like elon
musk
who was has only voted for democrats
according to him his entire life saying
he could support ron desantis elon musk
was a was an obama supporter so i think
the evolution that many of you probably
did a couple of years ago or maybe you
did it alongside me or maybe you're new
to it i think that is now being exported
across the country and thomas soule's
words there of like yeah i just kind of
knew what it was i didn't need to
proselytize about it i just needed to
think clearly about things and then the
rest kind of fell back into place it
makes a lot of sense and speaking of
makes sense let me throw you one more
clip from that interview with seoul
because there is a way to get this
country back on track ladies and
gentlemen really what we need more than
anything else perhaps is common decency
yes and we've kind of lost that it isn't
common anymore
i mean uh
when i was going to school and we'd have
fights on the schoolyard grounds when
once one guy was clearly beaten whoever
was the toughest kid uh in the crowd
would simply step in and stop it and the
other guy said you want to fight you can
fight me
you know
uh
that's what we need in the public square
now
yes yes but but with it with i mean the
pl there's only so much the police can
do
if you if you don't have common decency
that the the cops are not not going to
be able to handle it people can't be
knowledgeable about everything but they
can be knowledgeable about the extent of
their own ignorance uh even if they have
phd's
you're so good it's just so good
um
i'll make you a deal on the common
decency thing now uh yesterday i'll have
to go into the record here for just a
second i believe i called the ladies of
the view a bunch of crazy [ __ ] was
that the uh direct quote i got there
okay now i did that because they
unjustly called me and a bunch of people
that were at turning point uh nazis in
effect right so i'll make you a deal if
uh you're a producer over at the view
and you're watching this program right
now because you probably are actually
cause i know the view is on right now
but you can't be watching that so you're
probably sitting in the control room
watching this thing if you guys stop
calling everyone nazis if you stop
calling everyone bigots and transphobes
and all of the other horrible things you
call everybody willie's up too
right there is a way off this train
right the crazy train and the crazy
train's going to crazy town and the
problem with crazy town is not only
crazy town crazy but there's a big
freaking ditch before it and we could
all end up in that ditch together so
i will do my best for to add a little
more common decency to some of these
things but i also will mock the hell out
of you guys if you can't stop and i
don't think you can stop but i will i
will do my best if you try if you put a
hand out i too will put a hand out uh we
got a cold clothes for you in just a
moment do we have any uh comments from
the reuben report community today we're
having a little i think we're having
some kind of technical i'm getting the
one second sign i'll keep talking for
just a second i think i really think
that that's it right like the common
decency thing like you can put your hand
out there
you can say to people hey i'm here for
you
let's not burn everything down if they
want to burn everything down that's on
them but as seoul said it's like if you
understand yourself if you understand
your mind you won't be so hysterical
that's partly why these lefties are so
consistently hysterical okay i think
we've got a couple comments here from
the reuben report locals community jeff
says now thomas soul is a great example
of an old guy that has all the marbles
contrasted with joe who has lost all and
doesn't even pretend to look for them
you know that's a great point i'm glad
you brought that up because you know
when when i say these things about biden
it is not
and i've repeatedly made this point
it is not to mock him over age thomas
soul i think is now 91 or 92 years old
that interview was two or three years
ago
maybe it was four years ago if it was
that long man it's been it's been a fast
couple years but the point is he was in
his late late 80s one way or another and
he was still sharp and clear and cogent
and i would have basic complete
confidence that confidence that he could
be president
in a functioning way probably not ideal
because at 80 something years old you're
a little more tired you do lose some of
the mental sharpness like all of that
stuff maybe you don't want the 4am phone
call
but that's why this stuff with biden
this isn't about age it's about
cognitive decline and that's just the
truth genie says recession woman racist
they all changed their meanings five
minutes ago right we we're watching them
do with the word recession what they did
to the word woman right nobody knows
what a woman is anymore i'm not a
biologist and what they've done to many
racist bigot all of these things they
mean people who disagree with me so we
watch them do it in real time which is
why i always try to call back to uh some
of the things that have happened in the
past so that we don't forget tony says i
really hope that all these defamation
lawsuits are putting the squeeze on
these media organizations yeah you know
it's like
i'm a free speech guy obviously
obviously right and and the first
amendment protects our speech and we
have these very very rarely used
exceptions to it meaning you can't
directly threaten somebody yeah i'm
gonna i'm gonna come to your house and
shoot you you can't do that right we
have these laws around libel and slander
that are very rarely used because they
purposely wrote them to be so tight that
it would maximize the amount of free
speech but at some point at some point
if you
knowingly are are abject lying as whoopi
did she knew that she didn't know what
she was saying but she knew the turning
point must be bad guys because they're
not like her and if you knowingly
continue to go ahead and and slander and
libel these people whether it's whether
it's verbally or it's written word
whatever it might be
eventually you got to start threatening
back you got to start punching back and
that's exactly what turning point did
and that's how they got the apology and
look i don't know that the apology ever
you know does anything right the bomb
was already thrown out there the the
view audience already oh but we've
already associated turning point with
nazis so the the apology you know how
many people watch the apology or pay
attention to that i don't know um but
again silver lining people are not
paying attention to this stuff uh ladies
and gentlemen
tomorrow is a big day
tomorrow is my last show before i go off
the grid for august we're going to do
like a two hour live stream here it's
going to be part q a we'll make some
announcements whole bunch more we're
going to go through some of my favorite
clips uh in this past year since i got
back on the grid last september talk a
little bit about the move to florida and
all of those things and then i'm going
to do an exclusive
uh drinks i'm going to be drinking some
tequila maybe some other stuff with the
fine folks at local so if you want to
join us we're going to do a separate
live stream for you guys we'll do a q a
and all that good stuff at
reubenreport.locals.com that will be a
little bit later in the day it's five
o'clock somewhere we'll make it work
people
but we will be here live normal time 11
a.m eastern tomorrow for the big goodbye
livestream and then i disappear
no phone no tweeter
no facebook no instagram no television
no news no stelter no acosta no none of
it
and we see what happens so and i know a
whole bunch of you have been messaging
me on on locals that you're going to do
some version of your own kind of off the
grid whether it's weekends or a couple
days or just not checking social media
even if you're checking emails et cetera
et cetera so the fact that i've maybe
helped some people enter that world just
a little bit is uh is pretty awesome all
right we got a cold clothes for you see
you tomorrow everybody today 15
recipients of the nobel prize in
economics released a letter in support
of the president's
buildback better plan and his economic
agenda to support the middle class
including four nobel prize prize winners
recently highlighted in an open letter
is to highlight the fact that it's not
just us but it is a range of economists
seven a 17 excuse me uh nobel laureates
who have conveyed this will help address
inflation
thirteen
thirteen for excuse me fourteen nobel
laureates and economics said it'll
actually bring down the cost it will
reduce the deficit
and it was totally paid for and it's
going to reduce inflation
i don't know it's been handed out today
but by the way 15 nobel laureates in
economics released a letter yesterday
17 nobel prize winners in economics have
said spontaneously wrote together
14 nobel laureates in economics wrote to
me telling me that it will also diminish
the impact of inflation
nobel 17 nobel winners of the
economics have written a letter
just about three weeks ago to me
affirming that this bill would ease
long-term inflationary pressures this is
from 15
nobel laureates in economics quote
because this agenda the one i'm talking
about
mine
i told you about the impact of the 17
nobel laureates saying it's going to
decrease inflation not increasing